today there was a very large transaction
16 06 bitcoin worth about 1 billion was
moved for a transaction fee of a dollar
and 75 cents across the bitcoin network
think about that for a second somebody
moved one billion dollars of bitcoin
across the bitcoin blockchain and they
paid 1.75
the legacy system literally would think
that's egregious every single middleman
every single rent seeker would want
their hands in the pot if somebody was
going to go move a billion dollars the
bankers would want a little bit the
financial advisors would want a little
bit the platforms would run a little bit
the wire services would want a little
bit everybody would want to get paid you
want to move a billion dollars well you
got to pay us to do it the bitcoin
blockchain doesn't care it literally is
going to destroy those middlemen those
rent seekers and so to move one billion
dollars for a transaction fee of 1.75 is
pretty damn cool this is as bitcoin
magazine said here the magic of bitcoin
so to continue to see things like this i
think reiterate to people this is not
just about an asset it is not only about
having a finite supply in a world where
there's undisciplined monetary and
fiscal policy this is a technology
platform it is a payment rail it is
superior technology it is a
decentralized distributed network that
allows for peer-to-peer transactions
without asking for permission from
anyone and when you start to evaluate
the software based on merit you realize
that no one can compete with it where
else in the world
can you send 1 billion dollars for a
dollar 75 without needing any sort of
middleman and being able to do it faster
than any other service this is what
bitcoin can do and so ultimately i think
what we're watching here is that a lot
of folks are going to start opening
their eyes they're not only looking at
the asset they're also going to start to
evaluate what that payment rail looks
like and as we've seen whether it's
twitter integrating strike or we've seen
the lightning network continue to grow
in popularity or things like this where
somebody moves that billion dollars for
a dollar seventy five
over time there's familiarity there's
education and we start to get some sort
of adoption that looks like mainstream
adoption it's not enough to simply just
have bitcoins it's not enough to simply
just have the first movers instead what
we need is we need to have that
mainstream adoption if we then go and we
look well what is actually happening in
the market we can see that the bitcoin
supply on exchanges at the lowest level
it has been since 2018. now if you think
about bitcoin exchange supply one of the
key things here is that the bitcoin
supply on the exchange is a signal that
people could be ready to sell the
bitcoin if i'm buying bitcoin i'm going
to hold it for a long time i'm going to
go on an exchange i'm going to convert
dollars a stable coin or some other
asset into bitcoin and then i'm going to
withdraw the bitcoin into my own self
custody or my own cold storage and so
taking it off of the exchange is usually
a signal for long-term holders and so
the more bitcoin that's on exchanges the
more likely there is to be cell pressure
with the click of a button i can go
ahead and i can sell my bitcoin into the
market but if i actually go and i buy
bitcoin and i take it off the exchange
i'm adding friction to the ability to
sell it in the future because i have to
put it back on the exchange in order to
sell it but also what i am doing is i am
signaling that i plan to hold it for a
long period of time and so 2018 was the
bottom of the bear market of course
there was tons of bitcoin on the
exchanges at the bottom of 2018 because
we had seen a ton of cell pressure
everyone was ready to sell bitcoin now
all of a sudden as we get into the
higher ends of a bull market
what we can see is that people are not
ready to sell we are at the lowest level
of bitcoin on exchanges since 2018. and
so that is that signal that people are
buying it they're going to hold it and
they do not plan to sell it in the
future we know that about 85 percent of
the supply has not been sold in the last
90 days or so
and that usually leads to that supply
shock thesis we saw in october of 2020
when we had about 85 percent of the
supply not being sold for months on end
all of a sudden demand increases from
institutions we saw a lot of people
arbiting that greyscale gbtc fund all
those inflows led to a massive price
appreciation over 600 percent leading
into q1 of 2021. as we sit here today we
can see that not only is there very few
bitcoin that are actually on the
exchanges we also know that a lot of the
bitcoin that is being held has not moved
as well in the last few months and then
when you overlay that with the bitcoin
etfs and also things around interactive
brokers now letting ras come to the
market and also players like pimco who
have trillions of dollars all saying hey
we want to play in this game that
signals that there's going to be
increased demand there's a highly
illiquid supply and if history is any
guide that should lead to a massive
price appreciation in the coming months
it will be very interesting to watch now
one of the things that is going to start
to happen as the price of bitcoin
continues to go up is that people will
stop talking about bitcoin necessarily
it won't just be about oh that costs
three bitcoin today three bitcoin ends
up being about 180 000 you don't just go
to the store and spend 180 000 out of
the blue so we can't keep talking about
bitcoin at some point we're going to
have to start talking about sats or
satoshi's and those sets end up being
really hard to actually write out if
we're going to use eight decimal places
and so when you start to actually think
about a sat you can say one sat equals
how many dollars or you can give one
dollar equals how many sats and so today
what we've seen is that one dollar
equals about
1580 sats the ultimate idea from most
hardcore bitcoiners is that eventually
one dollar will equal one sat
as we've seen we continue to see that
one dollar equivalent in satoshi's goes
down we're moving from at one point we
were at 10 million satoshi's equaled one
dollar then we were down at a million
then at 100k then we were at 10k then we
were at 1.6 k and now we were at just
under at
1580 satoshi's so over time it is likely
that the amount of satoshi's it will
take to purchase one dollar is going to
continue to trend towards one and if we
eventually reach dollar parity where one
dollar equals one sat bitcoin will be at
a much higher price obviously and so as
we watch this occur it's important to
remember that as the price of bitcoin
goes up people will come in they will
not be able to actually purchase one
full bitcoin today it costs 60 000
that is more than a large portion of the
american population makes in a single
year on top of that what we have to
remind them is not only can they buy a
fraction of a bitcoin but they can also
spend a fraction of a bitcoin they can
spend satoshi's and if we begin to
educate people on the fractional
ownership of this asset and the ability
to spend those fractions of a bitcoin my
guess is that we will slowly start to
see a repricing of assets both of goods
and services in satoshis it is very
unlikely that somebody is going to say
hey you can come here and you can
actually purchase this
piece of uh this good from the grocery
store or this service and it's going to
cost you 0.0001 bitcoin no instead they
would just list it in satoshi's and so
that ends up being the next big phase
here we already have the mainstream
adoption of individuals we now are in
the institutional adoption phase where
financial institutions and corporations
are all jumping in that institutional
cohort really important we then are just
on the precipice of seeing the
nation-states start to adopt this
whether it's sovereign wealth funds
which we've heard anthony scaramucci and
kevin o'leary talk about the last few
days or it's nation-states like el
salvador maybe even rumors around brazil
or others starting to actually buy the
asset hold the asset or give the asset
to their citizens but on top of all of
that the next big phase is after the
adoption
we will start to start pricing goods and
services in satoshis and so be very
interesting to see this because on the
internet rather than have individual
geographic based assets my guess is that
we will start to see more and more
pricing in satoshis and lastly is don't
forget that this has been a long journey
this journey has been going on for
literally more than a decade it is not
something that just popped up in 2017 or
2018. if we go all the way back just to
2013 you know about four years after
bitcoin actually was launched you can
see here that the money magazine said
that the winklevoss's idea around a
bitcoin etf was number five on the 20
dumbest things of 2013. number five 20
dumbest things of 2013. well the
winklevosses they got the last laugh
they made the infamous purchase of 210
000 bitcoin right around that time seems
to have turned out pretty well for them
they're both multi-billionaires but on
top of that eric voorhees calling out
that anyone who sold their car for 10
000 and bought bitcoin upon seeing this
now has three million dollars so you
could have said in 2013 this sounds like
a dumb idea but now here we are we have
multiple etfs trading in the market in
the united states and many more abroad
and so maybe it wasn't a dumb idea maybe
it's just that the world didn't actually
understand what they were watching occur
and the winklevosses did so what do we
think in terms of uh kind of where we
are and how long this has been
building up to but it feels like now
we're at a point where it's really hard
to argue like this stuff isn't value